what up guys what up what up what up
welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel put a one in the chat if
you can hear me I hope you're having a
lovely uh most of you are in the US
let's say Saturday evening one in the
chat if you can hear me today is not
going to be a super long
live um but you know Pearl's going to be
talking talking talking
talking one in the chat if you can hear
me one in the chat if you can hear me
okay uh one amazing amazing you
guys okay
so I think that in the
past actually make sure you guys like
the video okay I'm late I get it I get
it I get it I get it like the video
there should be at least a 100 likes on
this video it's been scheduled all day
you know what I mean okay
okay so
um sorry all right I got
it in the past I don't
know two years all
right I I think sometimes my message
maybe gets misconstrued or my my point
of what I'm doing
here so I'd like to
reiterate
I have always wanted to know what is
true about the world I remember the
first time I
heard let's say I think it was Jordan
Peterson and I was in college and when I
was in college I wasn't overly political
I would say it wasn't like I was that
that's why a lot of old friends you know
might say that they're a little
surprised Pearl's talking about what
she's talking
about I was an athlete that is all I
cared about that's all I wanted to do
Pearl wanted to play sports
okay
now I remember when I saw my first
Jordan Peterson video and that
video I don't know it actually you know
it's funny how much Jordan Peterson's
changed but his OG stuff really actually
changed my life Jordan Peterson really
got me to think about my life more
longterm now to be fair when I was
listening to it then it wasn't really
out of a more traditional lens
or
but sorry guys but I do
remember that you know he really
encouraged me to start like thinking
more longterm term about the things that
I like to do in my
hobbies and you know I I stopped
drinking around then not to say never
but you
know um but you know I made it more like
of a rare thing for
me um I started learning to edit on
YouTube because I realized I liked
media
um I started uh working towards a
professional Pro Contra like I just
started you know thinking more longterm
and I remember the first time I saw
Jordan Peterson debate and he was
debating um that feminist on the pay
Gap and it was so
refreshing to hear someone explain the
pay Gap and what was really going on
with it you know because I was in
college and my school was very left I
mean we had
tra I can't say that word we had had I
caught myself see this is why I'm not
streaming as much we had
um you know a protected group let's just
say in our
dorms from I don't know like my freshman
year they had a
whole you
know what do you call it like row I
guess
of
those I can't say it because it's the
word that got me demonetized but you
guys catch my drift okay they had a
whole this is how left my school was and
I wasn't really paying too much
attention to it I'd see like the
liberals do all this stuff on the camp
pear was just having a good
time and I always I don't know I just
wanted to figure out what was true about
the world and I have always believed
that my feelings don't matter with what
is true you know I come from a Catholic
background I believe in God
I go to church it's not you
know I'm not a perfect Catholic I'm not
here to be your hero I'm not here to be
you know uh but my beliefs I never felt
like I never was here to be a preacher I
never was here I was here to figure out
what was true about the
world so when I first started listening
to Red Pill
content it was so interesting I just
couldn't stop watching in it I I thought
it was the most interesting thing that
I'd ever heard in my life and I get a
lot of flak um because some of my
opinions
changed and one of those opinions that
changed was my opinion on
cheating yes
yes
um and when I first got into the red
pill you know I I've told this story
before
and my dad is an angel my dad's really
an angel Sent From Heaven he
is my dad is a saint um my dad is the
type of guy that what the oh okay my dad
is the type of guy that will help
strangers carry their
groceries that's how awesome of a guy
like I remember he would see someone
struggling with their groceries he would
throw a and I know it's a little thing
but I'm just giving you an example he
would throw his stuff in the car and
then go run and help these strangers do
their groceries like my dad if I said
Dad I'm in trouble I need help he would
fly here
tomorrow he would he is just that kind
of person everyone that knows my dad
depends on him and I would bet money I
would bet money my life really my dad
has never cheated despite
being I mean categorically a high value
you know man and so when I first got
into red pill I was a little triggered I
I was like you know I heard Kevin
Samuels
um have a whole stream called high value
men cheat and I know I know I know I
know the whole chat is gonna say he was
doing it you just didn't know it's
possible but I also I know my dad he's a
saint he is a
freaking you you guys don't even
understand he's a a
okay um my dad's the type of person that
when I am around him I just want to be a
better person like that that's how good
of a person he is um like when I spend a
lot of time with him I want to swear I
just want to be a better person because
he's such a good person that that's how
I I feel about my now please don't make
it a weird thing you guys do that so
when I saw this stream I my first
reaction to Kevin Samuels was this guy I
think I called him a douchebag I you
know I was kind of
angry um but I couldn't stop watching
and I think sometimes when the truth
hurts it kind of makes you it just you
can't you know because if he was talking
complete
nonsense why would I watch it why would
I why would I still be interested in
it
um and what I came to find out was I
started a show and the way my whole show
started was
Pearl watches these videos online right
so Pearl said like and I just guys I
used to react to 10 videos a day
watching this stuff I I just couldn't
get enough I thought it was so
interesting um you know there there's so
many just genius content creators that I
would
watch
okay
and I would essentially I would go to
practice
and I I met a girl at practice at the
time and I said chica come with me I
we're going to do a reaction video today
I want I wanted to see what people that
had never seen this content before would
think of it just to see how true it was
what do people think so I brought her
and that was you know where we started
the the red pilling with you know
different girls from my team right and
you would just see their minds change
over time I mean I loved that series it
was so fun because it was never it was
just supposed to be uh not hostile just
like nice conversation between two girls
just trying to figure it out
okay now yeah coach Greg Adams is great
really great content creator really
really awesome a bunch of them are
really good but
okay
and then that evolved into a show
because you know I would bring over the
different girls and I would tell the
girls come over come hang out let's talk
about you know these Concepts and I
think one of my first shows
was um do women really like B like do
women really like the bad
boys and what I found out after doing um
interviewing over a thousand women a
thousand was oh my gosh these men are
right women love the cheaters because
every time I would interview a chick and
say have you been cheated on
yes yes okay did you leave
no and I just
couldn't I couldn't run from the fact
that men you know with options tend to
cheat and I went on it's funny I went on
Myron's show a couple of years ago and I
argued with him I I I thought I was
right he thought he was right and I
could see two years later he was
right I know a woman admitting she was
wrong
because he it was
true and
women categorically go for the top 20%
of men I saw this and we're going to
talk about this in a bit I saw Shu tweet
you know this girl named Shu on on
Twitter this girl is tweeting at me a
storm always tweet tweet tweet tweet I'm
just gonna tweet at Pearl and her Doomer
she'll just call me a Doomer or whatever
freaking these
people and even her so what does it mean
if couples are meeting online and women
only swipe right on dating apps
let's say five to 20% of the time what
does that mean we're
sharing whether we know it or not
okay now is
this what I wish to be
true is this me saying this is
moral or is this me
saying okay I think this is
true
and you know my question always is why
must women make everything about them
because when I start looking at the data
when I start you know asking questions
in real life interviewing a thousand PE
do you guys know how many people that is
I think I have aged I think I have aged
from doing these
shows
okay um I'm
gonna
okay women will make it about me right
so they'll e either say pearl but do you
wish to be cheated on Pearl are you
gonna let your husband cheat or they
they'll say but my boyfriend doesn't
cheat on me you need to find a real man
shut the [__] up Becky
sorry it's not it's not always about us
okay it's truly not it's truly not okay
yeah I did take one for the team yeah
and by the way oh my gosh blessing you
forgot to put this the thing on on
the um you forgot to put the thing on
the on the screen okay guys
um hold on hold on um feel free to send
a super chat I can't do it okay but I
accept venmo and I don't know what it is
because because it's usually on the
screen but I guess I guess today's a
free
day um maybe he'll fix it there's no
venmo or cash app well let me see I'm
sorry guys I don't work for free okay I
I really I truly don't um but I am right
now
anyways my cash app is pearly things
with an s p e a r l y t h i n gs feel
free to you know a cash app venmo is
wait wait we're gonna I'm sorry I hate
to be this gal it's just underscore
pearly things feel free to send a Super
Chat
because I am
demonetized and I do not know what we
are going to
do anyways so all right now I'd like to
reiterate so when I started started to
hear that Western women were
terrible I'm a western woman and I think
I'm a pretty nice
G but that doesn't change the facts okay
now I want to recommend this book okay
it's Aaron Clary a world without
men really really smart
guy okay 80% of women do not want your
average man
this has been borne out by online dating
data but no doubt also reflects the
majority of men's personal experiences
the vast majority of women are simply
not interested in the vast majority of
men 65% of women are annoyed by men be
it complaints of men trying to SL slide
into their DMS talk to them at bars are
just what your average girl has to say
about men on the internet the ratio of
positive things being said about men
versus negative shows that women are
clearly annoyed by the majority of
men
50% of women view men as competitors or
adversaries today women are conditioned
not to view men as com com of sorry not
to view men as teammates and certainly
not true purpose in their life but as
but the opposing team that must be
beaten worse many women are
propagandized to believe Marxist victim
oppressor narrative which turns men from
competitors who need to be beat to
mortal enemies who need to be vanquished
and punished
okay 30% of women actually hate men
whether it's the unconscious hatred that
blindly brings about bigoted laws anger
over an ex who didn't commit or a
conscious visceral hatred where
feminists ideology ideologically derive
their entire life's purpose from hating
men sadly a good third of today's women
in one way or another Harbor hatred
towards men
okay and mercifully 5% of women in
today's society consciously like enjoy
adore or love men if you look at your
personal experiences it is likely you
will have a handful of women women in
your life who actually like you enjoy
your presence even love you however if
you took the time to sit down and tally
it up it is a minority one in
now he has a part in here that also
talks about oh here another thing female
obesity rates speak directly to women's
disinterest in men if women really liked
men 60% of women today wouldn't be
overweight they would be in shape as
they would like to attract a man
furthermore 70% of women overall
wouldn't be overweight as they would
presumably like to make their husbands
happy this doesn't mean these women hate
men but it does mean that 60 to 70% of
me women simply don't care and prefer
food and sloth over a
husband
okay even choosing to be overweight
would be fine if men and women's Mutual
disinterest in each other would be
respected women get fat because they
don't like men that much and
consequently men wouldn't find them
attractive and leave them alone
unfortunately this does not sit well
with some women who shame men for being
fat phobic related if women really liked
men they wouldn't get excessive tattoos
piercings or Mar their body this isn't
to say that some men don't like tattoos
but there or there's anything wrong with
sleeves bull Rings or having your tongue
pierced but the fact that nearly every
woman under 50 has one look at I'm just
a unicorn out here no tattoos or
piercings sorry okay um we don't need
proxies such as obesity or tattoo rates
to infer women's disinterest in men okay
divorce has always been a Telltale sign
of women's lacad laxidasical interest in
men even after taking vows in front of
their presumed love of their life women
still initiate divorce about 75% of the
time this further proves women's
interest in men is not only conditional
but fickle and freeding though nowhere
as serious as marriage women flake on
dates anywhere from 56 to 70% of the
time and there is an online Behavior
there's
zero and then there is online
Behavior there
is there if there's if there's a ground
zero for the modern-day sex war between
men and women the internet is it and
then the internet is not the real world
it does correlate sadly women's online
opinion of men seems to skew only one
way bad women are either complaining
about men how they failed them hating on
them or blaming them for their
problems now I can read all this and not
take it hold on a blessing is he going
to fix it let's see
um and not take it personally okay
um press this button he
[Music]
says this one oh there we go okay we got
it on the screen thank you blessing
thank
you
So reading this reading
this maybe it'll put into perspective
some of these these tweets so now
shu is oh so interested this chick so
this chick and I'll get to this at the
end I'll get to it because she really
just wanted an answer from me the big
meanie meanie Pearl okay okay so I you
know she first shows these tweets happy
marriages are not the rule how many
Millennials why can't I
spell I'm sorry guys I just I'm not
a I'm not a speller right all right how
many Millennials and genz say they're
afraid of marriage because of what they
saw with their parents and this isn't me
just making this [__]
up this is me
I've interviewed a thousand people a
thousand I mean how many times you can
you can go on Tik Tok and find people
saying this to themselves they're afraid
of marriage because of what they saw
their parents go through my parents
fought all the time I I don't want to be
in an unhappy marriage d
d
okay 50% of marriages are not successful
just because they didn't divorce so many
men walk on eggshells at home they have
a fat wife who belittles him constantly
and we have phrases like happy wife
happy life it's cheaper to keep her now
this does not affect me personally
because I could say something that is
true without making it about me and I
want the women I want you ladies to take
notes not everything is about
you if you're happy if you're a good
wife and mother to your husb husband
maybe it shouldn't it be easy to
acknowledge that a lot of women aren't
every woman that I actually believe is a
good wife very few of you almost
none that if I say yeah women are
terrible to their husbands you know I
went home and my trainer she's like in
her 50s beautiful oh my gosh this woman
looks looks like she's 35 really great
shape really great person seems like a
good wife okay four kids
when I I I mentioned a couple of these
things and she said oh yeah it's bad
these women are not good to their
husbands most good wives can can look
and say yeah it's pretty bad out there
not everything is about you
okay I'm telling you when I see a guy
that's lost his friends his family and
his life assets all because of a woman
you cannot in good faith tell men it's
worth the risk to get
married now again I just have to look at
things
objectively I just have to look at
things objectively I look at the market
the majority of women are overweight the
majority of women are not
pure a substantial amount of women have
had abortions not the majority but a a
good chunk of
them and the reward what does a man get
from a wife that he does not get from a
girlfriend that lives with
him I have seen men lose everything and
it is not uncommon let's let's be super
nice and let's just for shits and
giggles it's higher than
this say 10% of the time 10% of the
time
this happens a man loses access to his
children it's more than that loses his
job is on the verge of suicide all of
that let's let's let's pretend it's 10%
of the
time would you take a pill with a 10%
death
rate
no and I'm sorry losing your children
having your reputation destroyed losing
everything
even a 10% chance of that is high and
many of these men do not recover they
hit 50 years old 45 years old 38 years
old they've been working for 10 15 years
building themsel up as a man just to be
blindsided by a vindictive
woman I didn't choose the world I was
born into okay I didn't I didn't do this
but I think part of being an adult
adult is being able to put yourself in
someone else's shoes now I know this is
crazy I know this is
insane
but am I going to fault men for treating
women like [__] when women are
choosing to be
[__] no how the hell how the hell
that's like me getting mad at a homeless
man
getting mad at a homeless man for taking
the free cash on the side of the road it
was free
like okay now again I'm not saying it's
moral
but I mean I I I would say well I could
I I could have seen that coming you know
what I
mean okay now I have seen so many men
take the Christ pill and get absolutely
wrecked in divorce court because what
these guys will do do when they do it in
such a sneaky way they do it in such a
sneaky way they say God can save you
from a vindictive
one now I
have no doubt that there
are maybe some couples that somehow God
has helped their relationship and
brought them together and I'm sure but
when a woman wants to be a vindictive
[__] she is gonna do it God no religion
is gonna stop her okay and the problem
is these pastors do not warn men and say
hey you should really think twice really
vet a woman before you get
married okay next by the way having
children in this country automatically
puts the man at a disadvantage I
interviewed a divorce attorney once and
I asked him if he feared marriage he
told me no she cut off the rest he said
said he feared having children because
when you have children in this country
they are not yours now again this is not
me trying to be a Doomer this is not me
trying but this is just reality this is
just me being honest okay regardless of
my
feelings you idiot
women God you guys are so stupid
sometimes
um regardless of my feelings
I know
that this is
true and just because a man has kids
does not mean he will have a positive
Legacy when the woman which many women
do and I have had friends whose mothers
have done this even when they were still
married told the kid that the dad was
this terrible evil man and now the kids
hate him I mean he's like wow I'm so
glad I got married
can you blame them it's
like okay you can't have children in
this country as a man without the woman
being able to drain you financially
there will always be a risk therefore
you cannot have a traditional
marriage yeah because a a girl is
traditional until she's
not I I get guys that message me their
horror stories all the time I have guys
come up tell me their life story on the
street this is
not and and by the way guys by the way
gray
divorces researched by Brown and some
someone has found that divorce rate over
for the O sorry all right
Brown research has found that divorce
rates for those over 50 years of age in
the US has begun steadily increasing
grade oforce has witnessed a steep rise
in the last year there were 16 million
adults 65 and older who lived alone
that's three times more than there were
in the
196s okay so you know you're not
even you're not even you're not even
safe in your 50s and 60s and you know
guys you know my grandparents on one
side they were separated I mean they
didn't divorce
but
I mean they lived in in separate
houses and and my grandma was a devout
Catholic
devout I mean is that a
w
okay I'll tell you what I refuse to do
tell men to sign up for a system that
causes millions of men to commit suicide
every year I refuse now think about this
if you have a a system okay now this
system only makes money off of men
getting destroyed in divorce court how
are the lawyers paid off of the
men okay how are
the um judges paid off of the men the
they're actually rewarded they're given
more money based on how much child
support the man
pays so knowing this information okay
knowing all of this information
taking it
in even if you just have a kid even if
you avoid marriage and you just have a
kid I I don't know if I would say
guys go do that
now if men choose to I would never tell
them not
to you know I I would never you know
every guy has to decide for for himself
I don't know your girlfriend I don't
know I don't know if she's worth it
I don't know if you should have kids
with her I can't say if that's a good
idea I don't know her so I I I'm not
gonna go out and say guys go and go sign
up for that system that
categorically wants to eat you alive I
just won't do it now
again you might say
okay that's evil that's
terrible but this is just me being
honest okay all right Matt Walsh Ben
Shapiro and other tradcons are not going
to save you if the good Christian woman
falsely accuses you of grape takes 20
years worth of savings and kidnaps your
children is are they
helping Crowder right
now is what are they doing are they are
they saying Crowder hey we're helping
you out pal no they reported they're
Network reported that he was a monster
abuser and they never retracted it they
never they never said to Candace Owens
you need to retract that statement they
never did they just all of the tradcons
these Christian
people that they all reported that he
was an evil emotional abuser okay so now
again
this isn't about
me as I've said as I've
said you know now she now comes at me
and she says I'm once asking do you want
to get married someday and I and I and I
asked her by the way this chick has been
tweeting at me for months for
months months months months months
months saying Pearl oh
Pearl you're so you're evil Doomer I
don't know what she's been just tweeting
tweeting at me and I say chick all right
let's have a conversation because let's
have a debate let's have a conversation
because you
know you've been tweeting at me for
months this chick says she doesn't want
to
debate then stop tweeting at me chica
okay no all right so she again she again
oh wait I got to go back to the other
one she again makes it what
personal so these over here pearls
tweets not personal not about you I wish
you well with your awesome marriages I
wish you the best I I'm so happy for
you but you see what she does she said
let's make this
personal okay so I'm once again asking
do you want to get married someday or do
you believe it will be too risky for
your husband if you do want to get
married is it cruel and I I want like
the world's smallest violin
playing to make a man sign into the
system in case you take his money and
kids or do you believe you're an
exception isn't it cruel to what is fear
mongering I mean if the facts cause fear
that's not my
fault I mean 50% of marriages do end up
in
divorce and you know I I've seen and
I've seen different I need to double
check the sources but I I've seen
roughly 10% 20% of divorces are
vindictive meaning not just not just you
don't get Soul custody or whatever but
that women will actively try to not let
you see your
children okay now again again
again all right is it cruel to make a
man sign into the system in case you
take his money and kids or do you
believe you're an exception isn't it
cruel to fear Monger This Heart about
marriage to your audience and possib
potentially Rob them of the same
happiness or misery why do women always
assume it's like happiness so let's
start guys if you want to get married go
do it that if you if you have a great
woman that you want to marry go if that
but but the key the key don't clip that
don't don't you dare clip it and make it
seem like I said something I didn't say
the key the key is if you want to and
you know the risks versus the
rewards you guys can make that that
decision for yourself I'm not here to
tell you how to
live I'm saying if
I if I if it was me I would be very very
cautious I would be extremely cautious
okay
if you don't want to get married do you
believe you would be a bad wife are you
dooming yourself are these my only
options I can
only if I do get married I I'm being
cruel and if I don't get married then
it's because I'll be a bad wife can I
get like an option
C can I okay because the laws won't
change in our
lifetime um I don't know maybe some of
you guys talking about it would be a
start but that's what everyone does they
just wave their hand and say well we
can't change the laws so sign up anyway
men buckle up and marry these [__]
sorry you know
um
so you can Advocate to change the system
but you can
also have a direct effect on the culture
at the same time and set a good example
for other women and men so I'm just C
curious do you and you know I'll answer
I'll answer I'll answer okay do you
believe you're an exception or do you
believe it's not worth the risk of
ruining a man I don't believe in putting
the government in my
relationship
simple simple and really if you're
marrying a guy if you really love him
it's kind of based on what he wants to
do if you're following his lead
is that crazy for me to say that I I
don't know like like I why is she asking
me about what I want what about what he
wants
[Applause]
so you know it depends what what is what
does he want to
do you
know
so again this
is why so my question really why are
women why are women so offended by
facts why are why do women take
everything
personal why why do women make
everything about them and feminine men
too you guys do the same thing um okay
guys like this video get get a like on
in the chat stop
being okay
I had someone told me
once talking about the future is just a
prediction I think that's kind of true
okay now I'm gonna go to my other tweet
that triggered pearls just the evil the
evil woman hater big old meanie Pearl's
the worst whatever okay
um oh apparently I sent a lady into
labor today because she rage tweeted at
me so much I sent her off a't that
crazy I'm like all right I wish your kid
well I should be getting to thank you
okay let me
find I'm trying to find this
tweet so back to what I was saying
earlier with the high value men
sheet um again this was not my original
opinion but when I looked at the facts
when I looked at the data when I looked
at the
statistic and when I interviewed a
thousand
people I came to the conclusion that
yeah the top 20% of men are screwing
these screwing the these
chicks I mean it is what it is okay
um I'm trying to find this where the
heck is this tweet where did I tweet it
did I tweet it this morning where did it
go okay let
me okay it must have been
earlier
sorry I should have been I should have
been
prepared
oh oh did I use the f
word sorry I I have a potty mouth look
at I'm not a perfect person I'm not a
you know that's why again you know
people will say
pearl they want me to be like
a
like this Catholic
Superstar I just I do the best I can all
right I like a good swearer
too okay so I said women of the past
used to understand that your husband
[__] a stripper isn't the end of the
world no I'm not high stop saying that
okay now what did I mean by this so I
got some people I got Tim Gordon over
here saying please take this down please
Pearl please take it
down sorry Tim I'm not it's staying up
it it's staying up okay it's I I'm I
mean it you
know I have a relative an older relative
people always make fun of me for this
story
okay I don't really give a [__] okay I
by the way
2024 I don't care anymore you guys have
slandered my reputation I if I Google
myself all this stuff comes up it's not
even true um some of you have tried to
pay people in my life for dirt on me
it's just crazy I just don't care I I
don't care say what you want I I just do
not give a single [__] anymore not at
all I'm I'm going to say what I think
and if you don't like it you can mute me
block me or kiss my ass thank you um so
women of the past used to understand
that your husband screwing a stripper
wasn't the end of the
world please take this
down okay um so sorry Tim again not
doing that it's bad for you to post and
others to read most everybody agrees
that infidelity isn't a ground for the
divorce but to say it
isn't Apostolic behavior for shitty
pathetic losers is just
stupid I mean is every guy that cheats a
loser
really and aren't we just starting to
compare
sin I'm sure you sin other people sin we
I I know there's mortal sin there's
venial S I get it you know I did the
cathol
stuff
um now what did I say I said it's not
the end of the
world does it have to be the end of the
world okay you find out let's say you
find out your husband screw a stripper
you're mad right he's not leaving you
for
her he's
not divorcing
you I actually I I know so many stories
I have a friend from college okay this
literally happened it made me think of
the story this literally happened to her
parents literally her dad had an away
trip he was a successful guy loved his
family provided for his
family he fell into some stripper you
know sorry you know now again I'm not
saying it's good I'm not saying it's
moral
but he was a well-off good-looking guy
I'm not shocked and it didn't break up
the whole family they stayed together
they worked it out um it's bad for you
to post and others to read why is it
true or un true does and this is what I
need I just need whoever watches me I
just need you to have this mindset is
what Pearl is saying true or
untrue does your husband band having sex
with a stripper have to be the end of
the world people make it through cancer
diagnosises people make it through the
death of a child when you look at the
grand scheme of things let's say you're
together 50 years one
time now is this me saying this is good
no is me this me saying it's moral
no
but that's what I think I think it
doesn't have to be the end of the
world so he says but your readers don't
know what you mean by not the end of the
world okay then ask we're all adults
here
ask um guys we need to stop with the the
racist stuff in the chat okay I I'm not
even I'm gonna I'm gonna block you guys
I'm not even
some some of this is just it's just you
guys got to stop that okay Daniel
Goodwin this is this is your warning
this is your warning
okay thank you going back to it so you
know I mean can we agree that cheating
is for honorless sad intemperate men who
create a gaping virtue deficit for their
families at least no I wouldn't say that
I think some gu just see a big ass and
some big
boobs and it's easy and there and they
go for it I think a lot of those guys
you
know they they could live with honor in
other areas of their life people
struggle with different
sin um I don't think it's a good thing
but I mean it's not a mistress you know
I
went I knew someone people always think
I make these stories up but I swear I
swear crazy things I knew someone who
was the youngest kid in a
family of six he was the the it was
roughly six I think
anyways the fifth one was with a
mistress and they worked it
out I mean it could have been I mean a
one night stand with a stripper or a
mistress I just think like isn't that
kind of dramatic I mean I'm just trying
to be honest isn't that
I like doesn't and the thing is when I
look at male cheating I think the
equivalent of a female cheating to a man
screwing a stripper is a woman flirting
with someone I think a it can be worked
through if a woman flirts with
someone
okay are they're going to clip it I
don't really I don't care I don't care
um but if she cheats yeah you got to be
done You Gotta Be You got to be done it
it's wrong right but that's kind of the
equivalent a woman seek getting
attention from other
men um you can't stop me or my people
what what are you crazy crazy
crazy
um if your wife denies you sex it's okay
to oh there there he goes he's hidden I
think
yeah thank
you
now again wrong but I I would say it's
like a similar equivalent so people need
to control their urges good luck look
outside and this is what is tough for me
people keep
conflating
morality like the
way your personal view of morality
versus what is true what is not
true so you know that's that's
my open invite to shoe you
know please feel free let's do this
conversation uh or stop commenting on my
tweets because you know stop being a a
scaredy cat
let's you know let's do it but these
chicks it's like they'll talk about me
for hours and then I say okay come on
beg
me and then it's like
nothing cuz she knows she's wrong she
would lose
um I think that's all my tweets for now
that's really everything I wanted to
rant about today no cheating doesn't
have to be the end of the
world it's wrong I wouldn't recommend it
I'd rather it not happen to me but it
doesn't have to be the end of the
world marriage is a bad deal for men
objectively because they're signing a
contract where the other one is paid to
leave and I wouldn't recommend it I
wouldn't say don't do it if you really
want to do it do it but yeah is this is
this crazy one in the chat if I'm just
if I'm just crazy and this is just
terrible two in the chat if these are
understandable
opinions
Pearl would you men oh I should tweet
that men who were married wouldn't cheat
on their wife if their wife would have
sex more
regularly I might say that I might next
one
um yeah and like
what you know in 2024 what does a man
get out of
marriage oh now they're this Brad
Willcox guy is just oh my toxic
messaging oh here we
go it's Pearl Pearl is just the evil
toxic
terribleness oh so evil
anyways thanks for tuning in guys for my
little rants you know
[Music]
um I I'm enjoying these so these are
going to be sporadic they might change I
might I might randomly do do them and I
might have to move the time around I'm
sorry if that happens um let me know
what else you want me to cover in the
comments I'm going to be very active in
my comment section so put you know put
whatever in the
chat like the video please like it on
your way out let's not be rude and
please send some cash apps and venos
these are the only things keeping the
channels going right now um we have to
make some decisions in the next couple
of months what we're going to do
depending on what YouTube says February
12th um so you know keep me in your
prayers even you Catholics and
Christians that are hating on me right
now like the video
subscribe